We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2, David P..
Here's a very specific question about IQ and
Donald Trump.
Hi, David.
And I'm a huge fan of your show.
I watch almost every day.
I'm 24.
I work in tracking and recruiting in Houston.
Right.
I'm just curious if you had to guess, I'd
probably just say.
Overall, I.
Because if I had to guess, I would say that
about 90, which may maybe for the average
person, not just below that, of course, is
president.
That is entirely true, though.
And you want to know something.
I myself feel he has the the IQ to do the
job.
So what are your thoughts?
So if you say his overall IQ, I listen, I
don't really want to speculate on Trump's
IQ because the entire IQ thing has been weaponized,
as as many of you know, with race IQ stuff,
with overblowing the importance of IQ and
the connection of IQ to different measures
of success.
What I can tell you is Donald Trump clearly
doesn't have the temperament nor the knowledge,
nor the attention span nor the personality
to be a good president.
He doesn't strike me as a good person.
He doesn't seem able to actually feel empathy.
He does not seem to be able to engage in the
sort of deep learning and reading that is
required that President Obama was able to
to engage in to be a good president.
And that's where I would focus my energy.
I have no idea what Trump's IQ is.
There are lots of people with a high IQ that
are bad people, and therefore, you still don't
want them as president.
So I understand what you're saying.
I think that I would approach it sort of a
different way, which is Trump has failed us
as president regardless of his IQ.
He could have a 160 IQ.
Who knows?
I don't care.
He's a bad president, and that's why he needs
to be removed in November.
Okay.
Next Thursday, April 9th, we are going to
try to have a coordinated membership explosion.
All right.
There's gonna be an email going out to everybody
on our mailing list at 2:00 p.m. Eastern,
11:00 a.m.
Pacific on Thursday, April 9th, with a huge
membership discount, the biggest discount
of the year.
Why are we doing this on April 9th?
Well, a couple of things are going on.
Number one, a lot of people are canceling
memberships because of Corona virus.
And we don't want to reduce ours.
We don't want to do layoffs.
We want to just be able to keep things going.
And so we want to kind of try to recover some
of those lost memberships.
We've also had some advertisers that have
had to stop or cancel campaigns with us because
they aren't selling product.
So they're not going to do advertising right
now.
And lastly, April is the anniversary of ad
pocalypse 2017.
So a lot of the people who signed up in 2017
no doubt are going to have credit cards that
have expired and membership payments that
are going to fail.
So April could be very ugly, which is why
on Thursday, April 9th, at 2:00 p.m. Eastern,
an email will go out with a huge membership
special.
I invite you to participate.
Sign up for our mailing list.
You do it at David Pakman dot com top right
of the Web site you put in your email address.
That's it.
OK.
Don't e-mail me about this.
Sign up at David Pakman dot com and you'll
be notified about the special on Thursday,
April 9th.
Join me on the bonus show today.
We have updates from the Pat.
Producer Pat Forde fiasco involving a fire
firefighter's water, a collapsed ceiling.
It's a nutty story.
I will give you the updates on today's bonus
show.
And we have much more to discuss as well.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.